bonjour et bienvenue dans ce check ins
le magazine santé de la rédaction au
sommaire ce mois ci une halte répit pour
les malades d'alzheimer cela se situe à
bourg pas à l'initiative de la croix
rouge de saint quentin en yvelines un
débat sur les dangers du cannabis
proposée par le centre hospitalier de
plaisir et les professionnels sont
unanimes pour tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
l'opération pièces jaunes lancé depuis
le chesnay par bernadette chirac et y
avait du beau monde à ses côtés vous
verrez ce soit dans quelques instants
mais tout d'abord le rôle de la maison
médicale de montigny le bretonneux
elle regroupe les médecins de garde du
secteur elles fonctionnent les week-ends
les soirs de semaine et les jours fériés
en 2012
ses médecins ont assuré jusqu'à 4000
acte c'est une façon de désengorger les
urgences
reportage à dimanche dimanche il est 16
heures le docteur villiers vient démarré
sa garde à la maison médicale de
montigny en cours il est accueilli par
sa consoeur qui elle termine la garde du
matin tout s'enchaîne
le docteur billets doit appeler le 15
pour prévenir de sa présence louis
docteur villiers jeu privat relève à la
maison médicale de guyancourt montini
voisins et la garde est parti pour
quatre heures pendant la première
tranche horaire le médecin de garde a
reçu 14 passion il s'agit de la médecine
générale pressé il s'agit pas de
l'urgence vitale il s'agit pas non plus
de faire le certificat médical sportif
il s'agit d'assurer la permanence des
soins pour un certain nombre de
pathologies qui n'ont il est préférable
qu'elle n'attende pas ou alors pour des
situations pour lesquelles il est besoin
d'un avis médical pour savoir s'il faut
aller à le clic
par exemple la maison médicale de
montigny le bretonneux existe depuis dix
ans tout le monde petit accès dé après
une régulation assurée par le 15 qui
donne le code d'accès le secteur couvre
notamment montini guyancourt et voisins
l'idée est née d'une volonté de médecins
de se regrouper pour assurer une
permanence de soins en dehors des
horaires d'ouverture des cabinets
médicaux classiques c'est-à-dire le soir
le week-end et les jours fériés 45
médecins adhèrent à ce raisonnement
l'idée c'est qu'il ya plein de gens qui
vont à l'hôpital aujourd'hui qu'ils
n'ont pas y aller alors ils y vont pour
des pathologies bénignes ils y vont
souvent parce que il y à une dispense
d'avancé de frais ça c'est clair ils y
vont parce qu'ils pensent qu'on va leur
faire pleins d'examen comme c'est
l'hôpital on fait plein d'examen ça
coûte une fortune ce sont souvent des
choses qui ne sont pas nécessaires en
2012 la maison médicale a traité plus de
4000 acte pour seulement une quarantaine
d'hospitalisation philippe belet souffre
de fièvre et de courbatures il est venu
accompagné de son épouse
je me suis dit que ça ne nécessitait pas
vraiment les urgences mais qu'il fallait
qu'il voit un médecin
donc du coup quand j'ai regardé sur
internet et que j'ai vu que c'était à
côté j'ai été rassuré l'hôpital avec
deux temps d'attentes avec le trajet
soit en sont si on a un enfant malade et
c'est vraiment pratique la maison
médicalisée sécurisé c'est à deux pas de
chez nous on habite à montigny
la formule fait donc ses preuves elle
permet de désengorger les urgences
médicales et le ministère de la santé
verrait d'un bon oeil que ce système de
maison médicale soit étendue à d'autres
communes alentours jusqu'à versailles et
cela les médecins n'y sont pas
favorables
plus nous allons être nombreux plus la
logistique va être lourde plus ça va
être compliqué alors que notre projet
initial et ben c'est de nous entraider
entre nous et on avec tout un système de
confiance de choix entre nous qui fait
qu'on est parfaitement tranquille c'est
un collègue ami qui prend la garde là ça
devient quelque chose de beaucoup plus
difficile à gérer avec l'ouverture d'un
autre cabinet à laitages des listes de
garde beaucoup plus compliqué à faire
la consultation de journée s'établit à
49 euros 50 65 euros 50 pour le soir les
médecins perçoivent une indemnité
forfaitaire versée à chaque garde à
laquelle s'ajoutent aux leurs honoraires
actuellement dans les yvelines il existe
trois maisons médicales fixe et une
maison médicale dit mobile sur le
secteur de rambouillet
s'occuper de personnes atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer c'est pourrait-on
dire un travail de tous les instants
alors pour permettre à ces aidants de
souffler un peu la croix rouge de saint
quentin en yvelines a mis en place une
halte répit amour pas et elles
fonctionnent tous les samedis après-midi
maison de voisinage des coudrais amour
pas dernière réunion de préparation pour
ces bénévoles de la croix-rouge
dernières consignes d'organisation une
halte répit pour les malades d'alzheimer
se met en place
tous les samedis après midi pendant au
maximum quatre heures les malades
peuvent être reçus ici et différentes
activités leur sont proposées
ça va être fonction de de l'accueillir
en fonction de de ses capacités à
pouvoir participer à un jeu
on passe ses capacités physiques va
falloir qu'on s'adapte c'est pour ça que
nos bénévoles ont eu des informations
très précises sur la maladie d'alzheimer
et pour le coup nous ferons des de la
formation continue systématique
les bénévoles ont été déformés par
france alzheimer nos psychologues de
france elsa demeures et le suivi de la
formation sera faire ensuite par lyon 16
haimer en apprend comment les recevoir
comment s'occuper d'eux
c'est 6 am la musique système pas la
musique c'est savoir
tout ce qu'ils ont été oubliés parmi ces
bénévoles françoise l officier aussi
déjà au sein de la croix-rouge et prend
son rôle très à coeur
je suis quelqu'un qui est hélas qui aime
rendre service aux autres
j'ai besoin six mois de bad est utile on
va dire la halte répit alzheimer de la
croix rouge fonctionne tous les samedis
après midi quatre malades au maximum ils
sont reçus les familles qui souhaitent
bénéficier de ce service doivent prendre
au préalable rendez vous afin de
constituer un dossier qui permet de
connaître les habitudes des malades une
participation financière est demandée
elle est minime 5 euros 9 fumeurs sur
dix de cannabis sont des garçons et ce
n'est pas dû au hasard ou autre chiffre
six adolescents sur 10 ont déjà fumé du
cannabis une réalité certaine qu'ils
font s'interroger les professionnels
soignants sur l'importance d'une mise en
réseau des compétences et aussi sur les
dangers de cette substance
une substance qui a beaucoup évolué
depuis dix ans le comité prévention
addiction existe depuis une dizaine
d'années au sein de l'hôpital charcot à
plaisir et depuis deux ans un accent est
mis sur la prévention du cannabis jusqu
alors les réunions étaient internes et
mais pour la première fois une session
d'information a été ouverte à tous les
pluridisciplinaire que peuvent être les
professionnels soignants et les
professionnels scolaires
elle s'est tenue au centre communautaire
en tant qu'infirmier déjà professionnels
travaillant sur un cmp on a repéré que
beaucoup d'adolescents ont des
problématiques de consommation de
cannabis est que beaucoup de
intervenants scolaires au fanion se
retrouve un petit peu seul dans les
prises en charge avec et adolescents
l'intéressé avant tout de débattre
ensemble de la consommation du cannabis
et de la première à l'éthique du
cannabis mais aussi de créer des réseaux
pour mieux travailler ensemble chez les
plus jeunes ya beaucoup plus de jeunes
qui prend du cannabis aujourd'hui qu'il
y a dix ou quinze ans et d'autre part
les produits le cannabis est beaucoup
plus concentrés aujourd'hui donc
beaucoup plus à des effets beaucoup plus
fort aujourd'hui que kylie à 10 ou 15
ans dans les centres d'addictologie une
très forte proportion de garçons 9
patients sur 10 c'est une pathologie
dont l'origine se situe dans le
développement difficile qu'un le garçon
de se dégager de la relation qu'il a
avec sa mère intervenir donc avant la
prise du produit car les troubles
psychiatriques liés au cannabis sont
réels c'est connu comme un produit qui
permet de déclencher l'ensemble des
troubles psychiatriques
y compris les plus graves 1 les troubles
anxieux ça c'est certain la dépression
c'est certain le trouble bipolaire de
l'humeur est certainement être est
aggravée et puis surtout ce qui est tout
à fait alarmant et le cannabis peut
précipiter du côté de la schizophrénie
des jeunes qui a priori on aurait pu
échapper à ce destin là on estime
aujourd'hui que six adolescents sur 10
ont déjà fumé du cannabis
solidarité pour terminer ce magazine
avec l'opération pièces jaunes portés
par bernadette chirac et la présidente
de la fondation des hôpitaux de france
est venu lancer la manifestation
nationale depuis le centre hospitalier
de versailles les caméras de tv fil 78 y
était bien entendu et il y avait du
monde
une venue très médiatique au centre
hospitalier de versailles à l'occasion
du lancement de l'opération pièces
jaunes opération qui permet d'apporter
un soutien financier à l'amélioration
des services pédiatriques dans les
hôpitaux de france dans l'année de
chirac en porte parole emblématique
christian karembeu et clément lefert en
parent à la fondation pedn a décidé
cette année de faire pas mal de projets
sportifs dans les hôpitaux pour aider à
la réinsertion de ces jeunes est aussi
voilà c'est important je me suis épanoui
à travers le sport et c'est important
pour moi de le partager
on ne peut pas laisser un enfant seul on
se doit de le guider on se doit d'être à
côté pour construire son avenir et en
l'occurrence ici pour essayer
d'améliorer son quotidien et
l'accompagné pourquoi pas dans sa
thérapie ici grâce aux pièces jaunes
plusieurs opérations de rénovation ont
été menées dans le service pédiatrique
la décoration de dix chambres pour les
nourrissons par exemple a été financé
une décoration avec de nouveaux meubles
et surtout des couleurs vont pas dire ce
joli ici on sait mais c'est dans le
comportement c'est beaucoup plus même
pour les parents d'arriver dans un
endroit
il ya de la lumière où il ya des motifs
agréable c'est pas du tout pareil qu'un
environnement où c'est tout blanc où
c'est plus stressant
donc ça ça aide en fait dans la
dynamique du service catherine gaud
league souhaiterait une aide financière
pour agrémenter les salles pour
adolescents ce qui ne laisse pas
bernadette chirac indifférente
nous allons donner
une impulsion à la construction de
structures pour les adolescents vous
savez que nous avons construit à paris
la maison de solenn et ce en face du val
de grâce où le var de port royal et qui
dont je suis très fier et nous avons
décidé de construire une maison de
solenn par département l'opération
pièces jaunes existe depuis 1990 elle se
déroule jusqu'au 16 février 850000
tirelire sont placés dans dix sept mille
bureaux de poste à travers la france
aller avant de nous quitter noter ces
rendez vous santé l'établissement
français du sang d'île de france appelle
à la mobilisation des franciliens et
notamment aux personnes de type au plus
et au moins dans les yvelines il existe
trois sites fixes de collecte à
rambouillet à poissy et aux fennecs
noter aussi une conférence débat autour
de l'âge et de la mémoire qui aura lieu
le mardi 12 février au centre culturel
des merisiers attrape la conférence est
animée par le docteur se gagnent
et puis enfin une exposition sur la
diététique aura lieu du 21 au 28 février
à l'institut de promotion de la santé
c'est à trappes voilà check up c'est
fini merci de votre attention
rendez-vous dans un mois pour un nouveau
numéro santé d'ici là portez vous bien